my wife and i acquired 100 million net
worth by the time we were age 32 and as
a result of that we had very different
views and perspectives on money and
happiness and i was recently interviewed
in a two hour long podcast with graeme
steffen and he asked questions about it
and from what i understand a lot of
people shared and talked about this
particular section of the podcast and so
we chose to cut this out and give it to
you in the next 11 minutes and if you
don't know who i am my name is alex
mosey on acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies that portfolio
does about 85 million a year and i have
nothing to sell you all right so enjoy
the video welcome to mozzie nation and
i'll see on the other side like a lot of
people make statements like they're like
isms like this is this way um like i
have this thought and it is and you're
like and i've just accepted that like
i'm always gonna have this like i would
just never speak that over yourself just
right off the bat because like you're
just saying i'm never going to get over
this thing like the statement you said
earlier about like at the end of the day
i just like i just want to be happy like
when you admit that you just want to be
happy then what happens is you create a
deficit between your current reality and
happiness which means that it doesn't
matter what happens because there will
always be happiness that is outside of
yourself that make sense
kind of yeah i mean but i would consider
myself no no he didn't get that at all
because i'm like looking like oh man but
i thought okay so here's my here's my
interpretation of it if i'm telling
myself that i just want to be happy then
i will never be happy that's what you're
saying no i understand what you're
saying right but i'm telling you right
now that i am happy now
good
so but
okay
wait graham i
what do you still think i don't
understand that so like deficits
deficits occur when we
speak desires right and so um i love
this statement um a desire is a contract
we make with ourselves to be unhappy
until we get what we want and so
whenever we state a desire like i want
this i want this amount of money i want
whatever you literally sign a contract
that says like i won't be unhappy until
that happens right and so like i had
this thing earlier on where i was like i
want to have meaning i want to have
great meaning in my life and i was
talking to a guy who made a lot more
money than me because i asked him i said
how do you create and destroy meaning in
your work that was the question i asked
him on a podcast and he was like
why do you think life needs to be
meaningful and it was the same exact
thing as the happiness versus like the
meaning thing where it's like i say life
has to be meaningful and therefore
everything that i'm doing
like i create this expectation of life
whereas if life just is
it just is
and it's the only way that you can
actually be there
it's just it's just pure acceptance
right
which is why like the whole like shoulds
of like we should work we should have
balance we should acts it's like i
believe marriage is a compromise like
these are just statements of belief that
are casting expectations out in the
world that are just bound to be untrue
at some point and then create dissonance
and so it's like i believe marriage is
marriage and i believe my marriage is my
marriage and i believe your marriage is
your marriage and like i believe that i
can work 24 hours a day if i want to and
that is all period not and it's bad or
and it's good there's no judgment on it
it just is and so like if i
get you know if i get
dopamine secreted in my brain when i
start working cool like and i will
optimize for dopamine and if i die i
know that on a thousand generations
nothing i do anyways is going to matter
so who cares like that's like the the
opening thing in my book is like there
are no rules like we live in this like
this like shoulds and have to's and like
like
happiness everyone talks about it and
it's just like
everyone is unhappy because they say
they want to be happy rather than being
like accepting like happiness like i
just am
period and then like i don't need to
judge the am it just is how do you what
do you say today i don't know
that makes sense yeah because so one
thing i noticed is if you're like i just
want to be happy
does that mean alex that you think that
at some point that will change for you
or something or you're you have you live
no i think that that will change i think
you guys maybe are taking what i'm
saying the wrong way i mean like like
alex is saying you know everybody has
different beliefs and there's no one
rule fits all to everybody and so if i
say i want to be happy that doesn't make
me wrong like if i want to live my life
that way that's perfectly fine
but the the thing that that what jack is
saying is no i am like happy like i but
i for me i like to make like a conscious
effort to work towards that and alex can
live his life like life is life my
marriage is my marriage um and it works
for him and that generates happiness
whether he's like thinking about it but
it doesn't have to generate happiness
that's the problem right
yes yes like right like but like because
it makes it like not because
it's like when people say like hey um
work uh
you know set these goals and like the
rest will take care of itself it still
makes the rest taking care of itself the
reason that you're doing it which means
that it's actually not getting around it
when people were like you got to be
process driven if you're like if we
focus on the process the goals take care
of themselves it still means that the
goals are important so like you have to
if if you want to make the transition
from like a process driven life which is
like i'm doing these things to do them
period then the so that i can be happy
so that i can have a good marriage so
that i have a meaningful life has to
disappear from the equation it has to be
i do them
period not because
i do them but then it goes back the
other way like but why because you say
so like because you want to right
like if you want to have if you want to
ascribe a meaning to why you're doing
something you can do it for whatever
reason
wow this is deep
so i mean this is what i spend a lot of
my time thinking of because i have
nothing else to do and this is what my
last year was was like trying to figure
out like why why i didn't have like i i
felt the exact same way while i was well
i had nothing as to where i have now i
feel the same like like people were like
man it was cool when the money hit my
account i felt nothing like truly like
not even like the two-day like i it was
irrelevant how did you learn all of this
did was this through speaking with other
people who have been there before you
thinking um i mean my closest friend is
a philosopher and i use that in terms of
like the actual meaning of the word
philosopher so like feel a to love and
then sophos's wisdom or knowledge so
like he's a lover of knowledge lover of
wisdom and like we talk every week it's
like the only standing meeting that i
have is we talk for like two hours and
we just talk about life and he's one of
these guys who like lives in a cave um
and it's like he got his phd when he was
20 like just a very brilliant guy and so
he and i just talk about things you know
he should uh share his contact
information
he's going to look for some guests on
the podcast oh i mean he's brilliant i
mean if you like dr cashew is brilliant
he's the he's the smartest human that i
know in terms of like brilliance and
their ability to communicate it um in a
simple way um and so
he helped me get over a lot of the
things that i that i used to struggle
with and a lot of it was just like the
language that we use matters a lot
because like how we say things is how we
think things and so like what i was
saying earlier alex and this is not like
this is not like a
slide i'm just saying like when i hear
like when i hear anyone talk like on my
team or or customers or whatever it's
like people talk so many things over
themselves and they're like i don't know
why i'm not successful and it's like
well define success and why are you not
and then what are the you know i mean
like i just want to do this to be had
like there's so many chains that they
put on themselves that it becomes very
difficult to live and so like i spent a
long time trying to not do that and it
was just because like i was unhappy and
i didn't like being unhappy and then i
stopped judging myself for being unhappy
and then i stopped thinking about it all
together and so i think that like i'll
give you a really real example for this
so one of the things that i'm vehemently
opposed and i'm like you no one give
gram flack you can give it to me
um
and like this is coming from a family
through like had out alcoholics and drug
addicts and things like that like i
really don't like the alcoholics
anonymous um concept of every morning
waking up and saying i am an alcoholic
high you know whatever and then they go
into their in their meetings because
what it does is it puts it at the
forefront of their mind and they they
literally label themselves every morning
as having this problem when somebody
who's not an alcoholic just doesn't
think about it they don't think i'm an
alcoholic i have to fight not drinking
every day they just don't think about it
and so i think to the same degree that
um like living a meaningful life is not
saying like
i'm living a meaningful life you just
are and you're not casting it you're
just you just are but don't you think
some of that is just
that inherent belief that some people
just have they're raised from that they
have positive experiences that turns
into a spiral but the people who don't
have that who are used to every day
being like i'm worthless i suck at this
i am bad at this don't you think that
maybe that like first step and like
getting in that direction is positive
affirmations of like i could do it i
could isn't that like that's better than
zero like i feel like we're going to
zero to one because i think it's exiting
i think it's exiting the equation all
together so saying i am worthless
instead of saying like i want to be
worthy or i am worthy just saying
worthiness doesn't matter but then
wouldn't you get just people not caring
at all yes yeah so i'm 100 percent of
nihilus yeah like i believe we die
nothing happens and like you know it is
what it is right but and there are
different ways to take that some people
are like life is meaningless and there's
no point in any of it which i would
agree with them and then the other
people are like there's no point in any
of it and so i'll do what i want and
some people see that as like very very
very self-serving which it might be but
to the same degree like you are
released from the chains of the
expectations of others
and most people
in my opinion that i have witnessed who
are unhappy is because they are weighted
down by the chains of their parents of
their friends of their siblings of the
whatever things the people that they
believe are casting judgment on them and
they care so much about that person's
disapproval that they don't want to do
the things that they want to do and so
if i think it's easier to get someone to
realize that none of it matters and then
build from there then to try and flip
the negatives it's just to exit the
equation altogether just say none of
this matters therefore i will start my
youtube channel and not care if my dad
says that youtube isn't real like it's
not about being worth it like
this is one where they're like i deserve
success like they don't no one deserves
anything but you can do the stuff that
gets success independent of your
deservingness you need a terrible person
and get and become successful so that
person doesn't deserve it but they did
these things that create success if we
define success as some material whatever
and so i think like if you can exit the
equation of like labeling
yourself
and then just doing because
because what else will you do while you
are alive it creates some levels of
freedom that
allow for clarity of thought and also
for the ability to take risks that most
people can't take